こんにちははじめしゃちょーですはい動画
のタイトルにもある通り
精子
を凍結しに行ってきたいと思います
おめでたいのかわかんないんですけども
精子凍結とは何かちょっと話させて
いただきます今回はねちょっとね重い話に
はしたくないんだけど割とね俺の将来が
かかってる話だからちょっとね真面目な話
が多くなるかもしれません
紳士凍結とは
精子をマイナス196度で凍結し保存する
ことを
静止凍結と言いますこれですねなんと
精神
反永久的に凍結保存することが可能です
選手凍結の安全性は医学的には立証されて
いるということにはなっているんですけど
もどうやって子供ができるかっていうと
精子と卵子がこう受精して子供ができ
るっていう流れなんですけども
選手は何で保存するかというとですねあの
ね
人間って生き物は
弱っていくのよはいこれはもう俺に限らず
みんなそう体だったり
身体能力とかいろんなものをなくなって
いく中
選手もね弱っていくんだって数が減っとく
らしいのよでねなんか身体能力とか体とか
そういうの弱っていくのってまあ別になん
かね年取れてそういうことでしょって思っ
ちゃうんですけども取り返しがつかないも
のってないかなって思った時に子供を産め
なくなった時どうしようって思ったんです
よもし仮に俺がもっとおじさんとかおじい
ちゃんになった時に
結婚が遅くなって子供が欲しいなって思っ
た時に俺の
選手がかなり
損傷してたり年取ったせいで数が少なく
なって子供ができにくくなってたら
うわぁ俺もう自分の子供の顔が見れないの
かとなんかね最近真剣に悩みましてそう
考えた時にまあまだ
比較的若い方ではあるので若いうちの
元気な精子を凍結させておけば将来どうし
ても子供が欲しくなった時に元気だった時
の精子が保存されてるからそれを使えるん
じゃないかと思いまして
精子を凍結させようかなと思いました
なんかいろいろ将来のこと考えた時に俺
めちゃくちゃ不摂生な生活してるのよ
寝不足とかってすごいなんか選手の現象に
影響があるらしくて食事の方いるとか俺
ダメじゃんこれダメじゃんって思って可能
性が続けてると改善すればいいんですけど
も仕事柄どうしてもハチャメチャな生活に
なることが多くて俺多分
選手現在進行形で減少してるなって思った
時にもう早めに今も選手あるかわかんない
のよ最近若い人少ないって聞くし選手凍結
してみたいと思いますというわけでした
選手を凍結しに行くクリニックに行って
くるんですけども明日いきなりできるわけ
じゃなくてまず今の現段階のはじめしゃ
ちょーの精神の状態俺の精子がどういう
状態なのかをちょっと明日検査行ってき
たいと思いますその結果が出て以降改めて
クリニックに行って凍結するってことに
なるのでちょっとまずはその結果次第いや
なんか昔だったら信じられないことです
けどもマジで最近の若い人
精神の量とか質が悪いらしくて時代だね
なんか生活がそうなっちゃってるんだと
思ういろいろな原因とか要因で俺はねそう
いう現代っ子の側の人間だからちょっと
本当に
将来不安なのでちょっと行ってきますでは
[音楽]
本日ですね2つの検査を受けていただき
ますまずお1つ目が精子検査が2種類
ございまして形を運動量などを目で見て
わかる範囲を調べするのが正式検査って
いう方ですでそれにプラスしてdfi検査
というのが正式のDNAの断片数までお
調べすることができる検査ですなるほど
今日はdfi検査ありのものでお伺いし
ますけど大丈夫ですかこっちの方がその
なんか損傷率とかも分かるって事ですか
質が変わってくるので僕結構徹夜してます
[音楽]
こっちで調べたいです
もう一つが感染症の歳月の検査ですこれは
普通の採決なので
睡眠とか特に関係ないことです
か結果ってどれくらいに出るんですかはい
結果ですね2週間から3週間でご自宅にご
郵送させていただきますそちらの中に入っ
ている結果に問題がなければ次回以降政治
凍結に移れるという流れとなっております
なるほどですね今日はあくまでサンプルと
いうか事前調査みたいな感じでございます
分かりましたこの説明以上となります同意
書なんですけど時間以降
入れるって
何
うわぁすごい
文字がすごいですね
これ僕が死んだ場合
破棄されるんですねなくなった
場合はなるほど
[音楽]
途切れてしまうのかだけが至難のとこと
なりますがよろしいですか
[音楽]
すごい結構
満喫みたいな感じなんですねここで
選手を
出しますじゃ行ってきます
結果確認です
やばい結構ビビってますどうしよう現時点
で
全滅してた
みたいな
はいお願いします
これで細かく見れるということですね
言いましたというのは入りますいっぱいい
ます
いいってことですかこれ
止まってるのもいますけどそうですね普通
の方もいらっしゃるもちろんです運動率が
標準で50%ですので逆に言えば50%は
止まっていても大丈夫となるほどなるほど
[音楽]
弱い人いらっしゃいます100人に1人は
言われているのでそんなに年齢の割に
かなり
いらっしゃいますどうですか5600万
基準が2000万以上ですので
基準の3倍ぐらい
運動率が若干低めです50%基準のところ
が46%
なるほどちょっと低めです運動
率
5600万精子がいるうちの動いてるのが
46%ですということになるので動いてる
選手のノートで言うと2500万の選手が
動いた平均が50%50%
量が多い
以上
欲しかったところが今回0.4ml
よかったなんか致命的に
バーンとやっぱ数字で少ないとなると結構
それなりに覚悟してるよ来てたんで
ちょっと良かったです
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
平均になってます1900万円
基準の3倍運動率8%さっきより若干高く
なりましたが50%の基準にはちょっと
満たさない感じですねあとはここの総運動
性指数っていうのが1回の射精選手って
どれくらいの精子がその中にいたかって
いうトータルの数なんですけれども計算上
1100万1100万円一応基準値として
は2000万円運動
精子がいればいいですよというところが
1,100万なの
基準の半分ぐらいちょっと今回定量が気に
なるところなので正規量が回復すればここ
はもしかしたらクリアできるかもしれない
ですね
1ml以上しっかり精子があれば基準が
超えてたかな
と分かりますか
5900万になります約6000万円運動
率が50%が基準のところ48.8%ほぼ
ちょうど基準
の中に含まれる運動精子のポータルの数
2000万から基準のところが1100万
なるほどですね
とりあえずは一安心したかもしれないです
ありがとうございます
はい1週間ぐらい経ちました
精子の結果帰ってきました
選手の量とかそういう運動率とかを見れた
んですけどもっと細かい部分というのが
きっと書いてあるのではないでしょうか
ちょっと俺マジ見方がわかんないからさ
本当にちょっと
緊張してるはいはい
えちょっと待ってよこれ
ちょっと待ってよ多分なんですけどこれが
一番いいんでしょうね自然妊娠が可能な
精液ですってやつなんかその下なんですよ
自然妊娠する可能性もありますが再検査
あるいは
泌尿器科外来の受診をおすすめします
なんかなんだ決して良かったわけではない
のかどういうことだちょっと不安ですねあ
なんか血液検査全部陰性でした感染症検査
に問題はなかった
え俺これ大丈夫なのかなんかすごい不安に
なってきたんだけど
[音楽]
なるほどね
えっとなんか
精子の
[音楽]
携帯
兵士の形がちょっと
正常じゃないのが多いっぽいですね
携帯異常性質って言われてるんだそれは
良くないのかななるほどただ携帯異常精子
の女性が原因で赤ちゃんに障害が発生する
とかっていう報告はないと書かれています
けどなんか怖いな
異常精神があるのか
えー
わかんないこれ一般的な数値がわからない
から何とも言えないですけど無声師匠とか
ではないっぽいですねちょっと待って聖書
は出てます
どうなんだろうでもちょっとなんかいいっ
て感じじゃないっぽいのでとりあえず
ちょっと
精子凍結すべきかどうかも俺も6分
ちょっと聞いてみたいと思います
はいというわけで再びクリニックの方に来
ました
選手凍結の当日ですね結果が僕あれよかっ
たのが悪かったのがよくわからなかったの
で培養してさね今日本当にテンション凍結
していいのかどうか聞いてみたいと思い
ますよろしくお願いします
結果ちょっと
あのーなんて言うんでしょう一番上じゃ
なかったのでそうですねちょっと不安では
あるんですけどそれって大丈夫でしょうか
基本的には自然妊娠をする可能性もあり
ますという結果にはなっているので大きな
問題は見られなかったという結果にはなっ
ておりますがただ一部の検査でですね
基準を下回っているものがありましたので
再検査ですとかもしくは泌尿器科外来そう
いったものの受診をお勧めしていますと
いう結果になっておりますなるほど
なるほどこのなんか選手の形状が良くない
みたいなそうですねこちらの検査正常形態
率という検査ですけれども
基準が4%以上100個中4個正常な形の
精子がいればいいというところが今回は
1.5%ということで記事を下回っていた
ような形になりますこれは何が良くないん
ですか
選手の形が悪いものがちょっと多いという
ような感じになるんですけれどもこれに
関しては結構検査自体が厳しめの設定には
なってはいるかなという印象はありません
ま1.5%確かに低めではありますが0%
じゃない限りはきちんと選手は見つかって
いるのでカバーできるだけの聖書の数を
出すことが見ていれば正常検体率が4%を
下回っていても大きな問題はないかなと
考えておりますなるほど
室でダメなら量で攻めろとそういうこと
ですねかしこまりました得意です
これって逆にその形状が良くないと何が
悪いというか頭の形だったり尻尾の形が
良くないということになります
ので自分で泳いでいってランスと出会って
女性をしていくんですけれどもなるほど形
が悪いと泳ぎ方が下手だったりとかそう
いったことになるので女性までうまく
たどり着けない可能性が上がるなるほど
調達しにくくなるって事分かりました
ちょっと今日しっかり
食べてきたので
是非今日はよろしくお願いしますお願いし
ます
なんとかいけそうです
[音楽]
はいというわけで
支援者が撮り終わったので
凍結する時こういうタンクで保存する
みたいです
あとは僕の選手も任せましたお願いします
ありがとうございますよろしくお願いし
ます
あーそうやってしまうんですね
[音楽]
こちらでお話しさせていただきましたはい
ありがとうございます
はいというわけで
精子凍結させてきましたなんかね
あっけなかったですねなんか思ったより
さらっと凍結って簡単にできるんだなと
思いつつも何でしょう別に今すぐ子供が
欲しいわけじゃないんですけど
欲しくなった時にできなかったっていうの
が本当にちょっと自分の中で引っかかっ
てるというか怖くてもしそうなのであれば
と思いまして一応保険的な感じで
精子を統一させてみました別にこれ皆さん
に進めてるわけじゃないですしちょっとお
金もちょっとかかっちゃうのでそこら辺は
本当に個人の自由ではあると思うんです
けどまぁほんと使用用途としては子供が
できないってなった時に使おうかなって
感じですなんか本当に食生活とか睡眠不足
とかストレスとかもほんとね現代の社会的
にはマジでね
妊娠しづらくなっちゃうらしいですタバコ
とかも本当に良くないらしいですあとね
自転車とバイクも良くないんだって長時間
の運転がねなんかサドルにその当たっ
ちゃってなんか選手の現象に繋がったり
するらしいですもうこれマジでこれも
ちゃんとデータとして出てるっぽいです
あと下着
窮屈な下着あれもね実はあんまり良くない
らしいよ機能が低下するらしいですあとは
体重とか
痩せすぎても太りすぎてもダメとそして
これが俺1番引っかかってるんですけども
えっとサウナと長風呂あんまり良くない
みたいですやっぱり
熱い場所にいるとその分なんか弱っちゃう
らしくて
サウナは入りたいっすまあそういうのも
あってこういう仕事でちょっと不規則な
生活してますし企画で大食いとかもし
ちゃうしでサウナも好きと俺の精子は
きっとこの後
減っていく一方だなと思いまして
凍結させていただきましたなんで悪いこと
ではないと思うんですけれどもやっぱり
ちょっとねなんかその自然妊娠じゃないと
いう部分でちょっと抵抗というか心配には
なりましたけども実際にその妊娠しづらい
夫婦の方とか妊活でされてる方も
いらっしゃるみたいなのでこういうのも
あるよっていうので動画にさせていただき
ましたとりあえず僕はあの保険として
でしょう保存したという動画ですこれね
選手の凍結したからといって確実にその
ステージで子供ができるってわけでもない
のであくまでなんかその可能性をちょっと
残しておいたっていう感じなのでそんなに
あの超期待はせずに
到着させてもらいました
そのためにまずは
[音楽]
結婚